kyle gibson overall 10-6 an era of 3.38
and his ground ball rate is still at a
very good level
uh his command though just hasn't been
what it was initially for the fills
ortega hits it out to shortstop sounded
like he broke his back
and went away here in the first
pulls it over to third to reyes behind
the bag has it plenty of time well
that's two ground ball outs
check swing did he go he did says brian
gorman half just standing at home plate
so
andrew knapp will just flip it over to
first that's a nine pitch hitting
for kyle gibson
the starting pitcher for the cubs adrian
sampson
sinker change up slider mostly sinker
changeup is what you're going to see
he'll sprinkle in the occasional cutter
and four-seam fastball the 0-2 record
but a sparkling era of 2.20 oh double
herrera will lead things off for the
phillies that ball's hit well way back
there it is gone
on to the concourse and it came right
back
solo home run for doable it's the 10th
leadoff home run of the year for the
phillies
and they take a one-nothing lead i don't
get this crowd right into it very
favorable start for the fight and fills
here in south philadelphia so
one-nothing phillies and it brings gene
segura up broken back round ball through
the hole on the left side a base hit for
segura
three fielders on the right side
inside corner and harper can't believe
it
stu sherwater rings him up
and that's that
[Applause]
chopped towards third wisdom they get
one there body to first
out there well done they actually
decided to review it and mccutchen was
called safe so a late look at it the
inning extended and now it's miller with
two outs and mccutcheon at first
it's softly on the ground
wisdom gobbles it up shuffles it over
to alcantara and now the inning's over
buddies with a 1-0 lead here in the top
of the third cal gibson six up and six
down the pitch swing and a miss he got
him hard slider down and away and boaty
goes down on strikes third k so far for
gibson
strike three called on the outer half
two outs four strikeouts and that had
some run to it
swing the miss he just struck out the
side he's paid four in a row
five strikeouts overall for kyle gibson
and he's perfect through the first three
innings here tonight to the fourth we go
ortega schwendel and happ through up
here
swing and a foul tip
that is strikeout number six it's five
in a row
and one out here in the fourth inning
slaughter that just backed up again
it's an awful big swing with two strikes
tom
sharply to third but right at the
reyes that ball got on him in a hurry it
sure did
swing at a foul tip he got him
seven strikeouts for gibson through four
innings
he's faced twelve he's retired the first
12 hitters mccutcheon at the plate he
bounced into a fielder's choice this
first time
drilled out towards center ortega almost
over ran it and makes the grab
the bullet was a little too fast that
time yeah this ball gets squared up
ortega gets a great jump on this ball
you wonder if it was knuckling a little
bit just the way
he kind of almost overran it
but a great adjustment come down with
that
ball bounced to first gloved by
schwendell the second one onto first two
another double play
the third double play they've turned
tonight and sampson continues to get him
to beat it into the ground one nothing
philly's lead it wilson contreras the
battered lead off
the other way to base hit
take that two strikes first hit first
base runner
patrick wisdom who flied out to right
field in his first at-bat will be the
hitter
drill to the air out towards center
field and you could forget it way back
and gone
patrick wisdom
number 26
and he ties the cubs single season
rookie mark wisdom goes yard and the
cubs have the lead it's 2-1
congratulations to patrick as he has
matched chris bryant in his rookie year
of 2015. and the batter down will be
alfonso rivas
that's drilled to right that one's got a
chance and that's gone
and the first major league holder for
alfonso rivas
back to back and the cubs have a 3-1
lead a rocket to right field oh this is
so awesome you know wasted no time jumps
all over the first pitch
congratulations alfonso rivas look how
excited everybody was for him sergio
alcantara with one down here in the top
half of the fifth inning
line drive base hit right center field
so the hit parade continues it's the
fourth hit of the inning for the cubs
after going hitless for the first four
innings of the game
so alcantara at second
two away rafael ortega at the plate he's
over two
that's the other way fair ball down the
line and now it kicks off the sidewall
alcantara to score
ortega into second and the cubs have a
4-1 lead
rbi double rafael ortega phillies are
down four to one they have only three
hits through the first five innings
down the left field line that's an extra
base hit rolling to the wall
and sigour is going to get to second
base
a lead-off double here in the sixth
inning let's see if the phillies can
roll that into some runs
bryce harper is the batter runner at
second for the phillies
line drive out to right field going back
out at his reeboks it's over he's headed
off the scoreboard segore's around third
heading for home the throw goes to
second base harper is safe at second
base he got his leg in
rbi double
his 33rd of the year it's a 4-2 game
race harper all over this first pitch
offering here
and he should be what was sitting on a
tee two runners on
one out
he's been waiting a while for a big hit
from d.d gregorius
bouncer toward the hole that's it to
right field to base it harper hustling
around third heading for home the throw
to the plate by reebos in the air he is
safe
he got his hand in
it's a 4-3 game rbi single for gregorius
number 45.
nick martini now batting for the cubs
left-handed hitter in the air towards
left center herrera on the move that'll
touch down
martini to second
that's a heck of a played appearance by
nick martini wow
great job pinch hitting in that spot and
now the cubs have a man in scoring
position so here's schwendell now
and that is ripped to left fair ball
it'll take a bounce and bang off the
wall schwindel into second
stay hot an insurance run right there
rbi double five three and now it's in
half
the other way
fair ball base hit
schwindel around third here's half
racing for second it's a double
and it's now 6-3 rowan wick on here in
the bottom of the ninth inning 13 games
so far this year 15 innings
and a strikeout there
for real wick as miller goes down check
swang did he go yes he did
[Applause]
swing at a miss struck him out row wick
strikes out the side to end it and the
cubs win the opener here in philadelphia
6-3 cubs win